oui et c'est un premier rencart donc il
est important que le tube est une tenue
sexy rien de sexy ne l'écoutent pas mais
une tenue décontractée sois toi-même
d'accord avant que di doo 2 est-ce que
ça là t'es trop décontracté c'est vrai
oui ça c'est non l'accord travail j'irai
donné ça aux pauvres de tapas en ont
fait pas ça c'est pas sympa ils ont
assez de malheurs comme ça fait toujours
le même
elle le fait tout le temps oui c'est bon
mais voilà il veut partir au métier
magnifique déboutonne un petit bouton
ici qu'on voit un petit peu les lolos
salaire de sa géniale c'est dingue j'ai
un trac d'enfer tu sais quoi moi aussi
dis donc tu te souviens de ton dernier
en quart ça remonte à l'ère de nyx est
ce que tu crois que ça m'aide
non quand même il me faut un mode alerte
qui a ouvert la porte
tu vas sur écoute tu vas sur les wii
party super les filles à l'eau à l'afp
soit naturel bonsoir vous donc vous êtes
là est ce moi regardez vous m'avez
apporté du feu c'est gentil merci
il a apporté des fleurs
si vous ne les aimez pas voyez vos
voyages de ces colis chez eux les
sentiers du tout la dernière fois
qu'elle a eu un rencard et on est sorti
on sait ce que ça lui arrive cette fois
ci le book club au cinéma le 6 juin
j'aimerais vous présenter messieurs
christian crénom quoi c'est un bon
salaire dans la sphère intime
oui et c'est notre thème cette année on
va quand même pas dire ça c'est mon moi
quand cessera-t-on moi tu pourra choisir
le livre déprimant et en gardant qui
voudra c'était horriblement gênant de le
tenir un lapin qui va juger ton chat
j'aime bien l'idée de l'histoire d'amour
mais on est trop vieille
pourtant ici ça dit déconseillé aux
jeunes publics
oui ça doit mieux nous corresponde nous
avons créé ce club de lecture pour
stimuler nos esprits y vivent y arriver
un d'après ce que j'ai entendu dire ce
livre est très stimulant
portant un toast à notre nouveau ligne
jusqu'à la dernière bosse et en lecture
les ferries le book club au cinéma le 6
juin
bonjour les filles j'aimerais vous
présenter
christian non nous avons lancé ce club
de lecture ou simulées nos esprits j'ai
entendu dire que ce livre est très
stimulant
cela fait combien 40 ans c'est pas
possible ça voudrait dire que je n'avait
que six ans depuis dimanche de la glace
or ça m'a juré de servir danger c'est
une professionnelle
c'est un premier rencart alors mais une
tenue sexy une tenue décontractée
là c'est trop décontracté bien sûr nous
sommes capables des fleurs
[Musique]
tout le monde se souvient de son premier
baiser je vous raconte mon meilleur
baiser qui est peut-être encore à venir
je n'aurais jamais pensé revenir un jour
ici c'est aussi bien car un de mes
meilleurs
[Musique]
maman il faut qu'ils sont un peu
surréaliste
il ya un homme qui aurait fait ressentir
des choses que je pensais plus jamais
éprouvé
peut-être que ça nous mènera nulle part
si la vie et je n'ai pas encore fini de
vivre la mienne
le book club on revient pas que tu aies
du viagra dans ma pièce monsieur je vais
vous demander de sortir du véhicule
je pense pas que ce soit une bonne idée
[Musique]
bon bonne fin de soirée à vous aussi
merci au cinéma le 6 juin